-My first guest
is a six-time Emmy winner
and one half
of the co-hosting team
of the #1 syndicated
daytime talk show,
"Live with Kelly and Ryan."
She also produces
the true crime series "Exhumed,"
which returns with back-to-back
episodes February 14th
at 7:00 p.m. on Oxygen.
Here is the one and only
Kelly Ripa.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Thank you.
-Kelly --
-That is so nice.
-That's a good intro
right there.
Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
You know we love
having you here.
It's always good to see you.
-I love being with you,
even if it's from this strange
setup in my bedroom.
-Oh.
-I feel like I --
I mean, I feel like
this is as close as infidelity
as I will ever get.
-[ Laughs ]
Dude, it feels like
we're FaceTiming each other.
Like, this is, like,
"Hey, what's up?"
yeah, which we never do,
but why not?
We can be besties
and be best friends.
Like, what's happening?
Tell me all the goss.
How is the family doing,
and how is 2021 going so far?
-You know, I don't know
what I thought.
I think I thought, like, 2021
would be like the sequence
of "The Wizard of Oz" where --
You know when they're
in black and white,
and then the house lands,
and she opens the door,
and everything's in color?
I think I thought,
like, 2021 would happen,
and then, like, it's over.
We can all come outside, guys,
and go play in the park.
-Yeah.
-Pretty much the same.
-It didn't quite
happen yet, yeah.
I want to talk to you
about the true crime series
that you produce
called "Exhumed."
I love the true crime,
but I have to watch
during the daytime.
I can't do it at nighttime,
or else --
-What you have to do --
I'm going to plug my show and
do you a favor at the same time.
So, on Sundays, okay,
on Oxygen Channel,
they have a "Snapped" marathon.
Now, do you know
about "Snapped"?
-Yes, I've seen "Snapped."
-"Snapped" is basically
hours and hours and hours
of programming
about women who snap one day
and kill their spouse.
-Yep. No, I've seen enough
where I go, "Honey,
it's banned in our house."
-Exactly. And so it started
getting banned in our house.
Like, I'd be cooking
Sunday dinner,
and you have to understand,
like, I don't
take pleasure in it.
I actually do it
with a resentful heart.
So I'd be sitting there,
like, you know,
chopping carrots with an ax,
and the kids are like, "Mom's
watching 'Snapped' again."
-Yeah. Of course.
-And so that's how we came up
with this idea for a show,
"Exhumed, which is basically
what happens when people --
They die under mysterious
circumstances sometimes,
and they're buried, and then
suddenly there's a wrinkle,
and it turns out
maybe this person
had more than one person
in their life that died, right?
And so you have to
exhume the body.
And what better way to celebrate
Valentine's Day, I thought,
than to have new episodes
of "Exhumed."
-February 14th,
there's back-to-back episodes
of "Exhumed."
I love these shows.
I want to show a clip
from the new season
of "Exhumed."
Take a look at this clip.
-With 46 years
of new developments
in forensic science,
the evidence buried with Loretta
could be the key
to catching Egley.
-I call Heidi Jones up,
and I told her we were going
to exhume the body,
and I got exactly
the answer I expected.
-I said, "Get me a shovel.
I'll help dig."
-Ooh.
Kelly, I want to congratulate
you, because this is very big.
This month marks
your 20th anniversary
of co-hosting your show "Live."
That is an awesome
achievement in television.
-I keep thinking
that it's three years.
I'm like,
"It's only been three years.
I don't understand
what the big deal is."
-I mean, can you --
What do you remember
about getting the job
in the first place?
Was this something
that you always imagined?
-No. Oh, no, no, no.
I actually think that the fact
that I did not
have any anticipation
about getting that job at all
actually worked greatly
to my advantage,
because I wasn't going after it.
I was asked to fill in for a
fill-in host at the last minute,
so it took any stakes
or any, like, nervousness
that I probably
would have had away.
My only concern was that
I was very early pregnant
with our daughter, Lola.
-Yes.
-And nobody knew. Nobody knew.
Mark and I knew,
and nobody else knew.
And they said,
"There's going to be a psychic,
and she's going
to give you a reading,
if you don't mind, because
we're doing psychic week."
And I said to Mark, "I've got to
cancel. I can't do this."
-"She's gonna bust me."
-Right. And he goes, "Oh, what,
you think a psychic's going
to figure out you're pregnant?"
I go, "Well, what if she does?
Isn't that what,
like, psychics do?"
And, Jimmy,
not only did she figure out
I was pregnant in three seconds,
but she was like, "Your
grandmother, Dee, is here."
And I was like, "Mm, nope,
that's not her name."
She's like, "Esther,
but her nickname is Dee."
Like, she figured it all out.
-No, I don't know
if I could handle it.
That's wild stuff.
Hey, over the incredible
20 years that you've hosted,
there have been so many
memorable moments,
and I wanted to challenge you
just to see how many
of those moments you remember
in the
"Know Your Show Challenge."
Alright, I'm gonna ask a series
of rapid-fire questions,
You have to answer
as fast as possible
or whatever you want to do.
You're Kelly Ripa.
Please. Alright.
Who was your first celebrity
guest interview as co-host?
-I know that. Ray Liotta.
-Number 2, who was
your celebrity guest
on your show this morning?
-Uh...
[ Both laugh ]
-That's the best part.
That is the best part.
I've done it, too.
-If I asked you --
At 1:00 a.m., if I asked you,
you would not know that
I was here.
-[ Chuckles ]
You, of course, I would know.
Alright. Good. I got you.
You broke
a Guinness World Record
for getting something thrown at
your face 24 times in a minute.
What was it?
-I think pies.
-Yes, it was banana cream pies.
-Okay, amazing.
-You've done everything.
How many Daytime Emmy Awards
have you won for "Live"?
-Oh, for -- I don't know.
I heard you say that I won six,
which I think is also incorrect,
but I'm going to say like three.
-[ Laughs ]
-Three?
-It's COVID.
We have no research department.
Give us a break.
-I don't know.
-Three. You won more than three.
-Oh, this question
is really from the heart.
You have very high stools
on your show.
My question is, have you ever
fallen off your stool while
taping?
-I've -- Oh.
I don't think so.
I would say no.
-Has your co-host
ever fallen off the stool?
-Yes. Yes.
[ Both laugh ]
We have a hard time
keeping him in the stool.
-I want to show a clip,
'cause we've only shown it
50 times on our show.
Please roll the tape.
-Us, too.
-It's my favorite thing.
-Gold from Buffalo, New York.
Lookit. [ Laughs ]
It's the best thing ever. Ah.
Thanks for --
Let's keep more
of those memories going.
Here's to 20 more.
Congratulations on your
20th anniversary of "Live."
And be sure, everybody,
check out "Exhumed" on Oxygen
on Valentine's Day.
It's a back-to-back episode.
Kelly Ripa, we love you.